Joe's with us in Joplin Missouri Hey Joe
how are you okay Dave are you done
better than I deserve sir how can I help
alright pretty much a new listen listen
very long but and I'm like when I'm
hearing and he got me motivated I about
your books yesterday the workbook and
the did be at varied of our app and the
problem isn't hundred dollars in the
hole when I do all the budgeting and
that's not what saving or anything and I
I don't know what to do
doesn't know where to start I got three
vehicle payment which is done but and
I'm just okay Co on these cars each ten
thousand three hundred and the motor
blue when I bought it and I got
different mounts or four or forty five
hundred my product I owe nine thousand
on it
[Music]
harley-davidson 11:5 on it and what
other debts have you got not counting
these car debts
I've got about eight thousand medical
bills I've got a stupid title long on a
vehicle that's cheap me a card out
that's paid for let my son drives
sometimes furniture was just a title
womb a thousand dollars okay
[Music]
furniture loan beds loan how much a bed
loan is a thousand furniture loan as a
thousand right around it overrides in
about four thousand dollars and
[Music]
again I mean are we pay for my kids
lunch stuff anymore miss I'm you know I
don't know whether to gotcha
what's your household income before
taxes I make fifty five my wife's 20 so
about seventy five before everything
comes out okay all right cool are you
putting any money into retirement I
splitting 5% in and I'm not going down
to 1% to give me a little more money
yeah how big was your tax return last
year eight thousand eight thousand okay
no all right cool okay fun and how much
do you own your home I rant okay good
all right so here and you're what 45
years old 38 38 okay that's about the
right and run zone what I was gonna
guess so good good three kids that I'm
still down here here's what you've been
doing you you work your butt off and you
pay no attention to money and it has
been whipping your butt for 15 years I
agree and consequently you get a pinch
and you do something stupid then you're
getting another pinch and do something
else stupid and then the stupid piles up
and you you just get you're just trying
to make it hand the mouth that's thank
God it's Friday oh god it's Monday
exactly been there myself brother that's
how I can tell you're hard-working guy
but you've not been paying attention to
the money part and it's kicking your
butt so we're going to turn that around
the day all right here's a couple things
we're gonna do immediately today you
stop all contributions to your
retirement today and you go in and you
change your w-4 at the at your payroll
withholding because you have way too
much being withheld when you get an
$8,000 refund
what that really means is that somewhere
around five somewhere around $600 a
month
too much is coming out of your check
right okay and they take too much out
and then they give it back to you
in April Santa Claus does not live in
Washington DC that money that you got
back was your money that you gave them
too much of you follow me
yes sir so changer withholding by six
hundred dollars a month more coming home
that's going to mean this year you'll
still get a refund because you've
already still done it for this year but
next year you hopefully won't get a
refund because all a refund is is a
return of too much money paid in that's
a savings account with no interest and
you don't need a savings account with no
interest right now you need money
exactly okay so six hundred bucks a
month coming home more plus we're gonna
not have the 401k coming home and that
money's gonna don't go in so that's all
going to come home starting right now a
hundred percent of it to stop everything
if you've got any gimmicks insurance
like cancer insurance all those little
stuff stop all of that the only thing
you need is just straight health
insurance that's all you need it work
straight health insurance and if there's
a long term disability you might look at
that okay and then we're gonna start
looking at what we can sell like the
Harley may be the kid car and we're
gonna live food first shelter second
lights and water third car payments
fourth and we're gonna get on beans and
rice around this place and get this
budget balanced and pick up extra work
and have a big garage sale and sell
everything in sight and start turning
this around but when you can start
paying attention to this and you get
this budget balanced and you get on a
mission to get rid of this debt you can
turn it hold on I'm gonna put you guys
into Financial Peace University our nine
week class I want you to turn this you
call me back and tell me you did it hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]